bugger McFarlane with the mothership
he's an analyst on Monday Night Football
on Christmas Eve booger in the guy's Joe
testator Jason Witten and Lisa Salters
have the regular season finale the
Broncos and the Raiders 8:15 Eastern on
ESPN or do you think you could take
Jason Witten in the Octagon you know
what about 240 is probably closer to 250
netweaver on the road all here so that
would be a battle I like to think low
man still football so you know me being
only 6 1 I think I like my chances what
did you weigh when you play was about
315 Wow
is it harder to put it on or take it off
come on now you've been living alone I
got up to about 3:30 Dan after I got
done playing pretty easily you know low
known on the cards with the mac and
cheese I grew up in the country I'm a
country boy so fried chicken and mac and
cheese is like in my name it's like a
snack you walk by and grab and then
about 2 or 3 years ago man I started
looking around I got two little kids man
I'm like you know what if you're gonna
be around here for these kids long term
and you got to change and so I cut out
the sugar the bread the rice a lot of
the carbs I lost about 45 and so I walk
around at about 280 now and I feel
really really good about life now buddy
who was the biggest man you faced when
you were playing I mean Larry Allen
would break the huddle and there's no
lie he would break the hodo he's
probably 335 340 by 6-3
I mean arm as big as most people's
thighs and he'd have a dip in and and it
was the most intimidating thing I'd ever
seen you see a guy that big break the
huddle with a different defensive
players talk about Larry Owen with such
reverence probably more so than any
other offensive lineman in history
everybody has it feels like a Larry
Allen story or defensive players would
sick out it's like when you knew your
left hand facing uh
Andy Johnson in your left-handed hitter
all of a sudden you got sick you know
you take yourself out of the lineup
Larry Allen did that to defensive
players you know I think other defensive
players we recognize great I mean most
offensive linemen are fat slow can't
move they just want to get in the way
home they always needed help they always
ask to double-team and so when you're
going in some of the truly great ones
like a Larry Allen like a Steve
Hutchison like a Walter Jones you
recognize the greatness that they are
and I think it's just a respect factor
which I'm pretty sure if you ask
somebody office environment about some
of the great defensive linemen you go
against I think you you feel that same
respect when it comes to you know guys
like a Warren Sapp or or Derrick Brooks
or a Kevin Green like when you go
against great guys you respect great
your role on Monday Night Football
you're outside on the booger mobile but
you're out there and all the elements no
matter what so if it's snowing hard
raining hard you're out there no matter
what right absolutely
there is no circumstance where you're
allowed in the booth well here's the
deal we've been fortunate this year what
we haven't encountered anything crazy
I'm sure if it started lightening and I
think they will probably cancel the game
but nobody would have to tell me hey you
need to get on because I see the strike
of lightning I'm getting down and you
know they're gonna have to do a two-man
broadcast you know without me but the
weapons been good so far
you know it was a little chilly in Green
Bay we got a little mist in Seattle it
wasn't really that bad so whether we be
good this year
you get yelled at you know what here's
think about it people always say man I
just here's what they don't realize I
got a headset on and I can't hear
anything number one number two most of
the fans have been very very cool I'll
say 99% of fans I've been cordial before
and after the game I walk up and down
the sideline sign autographs take
pictures you know there was one guy who
had a sign who said something but the
overwhelming majority of the fans have
been really really cause you to me and
hospitable in most stadiums that I've
gone in I think the biggest attention
for
the setup that I have came about
midseason there was this fan from New
York who came to Atlanta to see the
Giants play the Falcons and he took a
video and because he's a quote-unquote
super fan whatever the hell that means
you know he sent this video out and
people just started following in just
like it's like anything
social media is built on negativity and
so I got a hundred thousand people
saying then get out of the way and I'm
saying to myself you know what
not even a percent of you guys have
never been the stadium where I've been
there but just to kind of get on the
perception reality train everybody
jumped on but then it really hasn't been
a big deal I I think the whole idea of
it has been really really good addition
and hopefully fans have enjoyed the
carpet talking a booger McFarlane of the
mothership their Monday night game its
Denver against the Oakland Raiders best
defense you've seen so far this year is
you know I mean you know the Cowboys
defense was pretty good I think the Rams
defense has the potential to be really
good the Saints are playing really well
at the right time I don't think there's
a dominant defense or a dominant team
but at least then I I think defenses
that have the potential when they need
to get a stop and ultimately that's what
it's going to come down but could the
Bears win on just defense alone could
the Bears go to the Super Bowl and they
are truly good I still think mr. Fisk is
gonna have to make a couple plays and
and here's the plays I'm talking about
I'm not talking about scrambled around
run around and everybody gets up
screaming [ __ ] I'm talking about at
some point it's gonna be thirty to ten
thirty twelve
he's like to drive back when his back
foot and throw something about a 15 18
yard big and he's got to do that he's
probably cold well I'll do that in
probably a hostile environment I think
that's the thing that I need to see from
him to be more consistent now that
defense is really great but you can have
to score points to win and I think he
can do it I just need to see it against
a New Orleans maybe done in the dome I
need to see it against the Rams on LA
yeah that'll be the test for him yeah
I'm right there with you I think is same
with yard golf the abuse of the two
quarterbacks I have the biggest concerns
but the upside is you could go to the
Super Bowl the downside is you could
lose your first game golf with where
they are girlies banged up they just
don't feel like they're in sync quite as
they feel like they're a little more
vulnerable here the most dangerous team
going into the postseason will be who
okay thanks I think they're the best
football team on the other side of the
conference when I say other side being
the AFC you know everybody's talked so
much of our Patrick Malone's and Andy
Reid and then don't get me wrong they've
been phenomenal phenomenal but but I
think if you looked at top to bottom
who's the most complete team team is
offensively defensively special teams
were I would lean toward the Chargers
over the Chiefs you know I'm not gonna
ever discount Brady and Belichick but I
think the dude yesterday with Josh
Gordon is gonna hurt them at some point
Pittsburgh being it is too inconsistent
for me defensively I would put a little
coin toward the charges and feel pretty
good about it going into the playoffs
the most valuable non quarterback is who
Aaron Donald because if Aaron Donald
plays great and dominate here's what he
does
number one he makes plays but number two
he kind of sets the table for everybody
else with you know Dante Fowler Jr and
diamond consume maybe he'll come out of
hiding and get off the still cards at
some point if Donald is Donald to me
he's the best defensive player in the
game and that's no disrespect to Khalil
Mac dizzy why don't any of those guys
but I just feel when you have a dominant
force coming up the middle of your
office it's different than an eighth guy
best team is who Wow I'll give you one
from each conference I'll give you the
Chargers on the AFC side and on the
inside man I know it doesn't look like
it but I'm still gonna lean toward the
Rams because I think over the last two
years you just look at a two-year sample
what the Rams have done I think they've
been the most consistent now they
haven't always played played well
because their offensive linemen really
got punked by the Eagles but I think
I'm going with the 2-year sample I'm
going with the fact that Sean McVeigh
might be one of if not the most
innovative minds I've seen them all time
and I'm just gonna lean on consistency
and I think to leave and Peter's on the
defensive side with Donnell and you know
Jared golf if they can protect your golf
I think Jared Golf can get it done but I
like you has the most questions about he
and 450 cam Jordan of the Saints with
the Steelers coming to town talked about
Ben Roethlisberger not being one of the
greats of this era talking about is he a
Hall of Famer your thoughts if cam
Jordan was your teammate and you heard
that he had said those comments
you're a locker over from cam Jordan
what do you say I don't say anything at
all here's what I say I say you know
what you know you know you created and
kind of stirred the hornet's nest but
guess what no problem because once you
get out there on the field and and this
is the thing about bulletin board
material and talking it's good for us
because we got three or four hours to
field on shows Dryden column but once
that ball is kicked down in New Orleans
Ben Roethlisberger is not gonna break
the huddle saying man I got to go
through camp George right or wrong he's
gonna break the hood of trying to score
points now the postgame press conference
will probably be a little bit livelier
if it still is when and vice-versa if
the Saints win but you know to that
point i do think Ben Roethlisberger is a
Hall of Famer
I think Phillip Rivers is a Hall of
Famer I think Eli Manning although I
don't think he gets in as quick as those
other two III do think eventually he'll
get in also all right but if I said you
had to pick you're starting your team
with rivers or Roethlisberger and you
know how they've played in their career
you know what you got who you start in
your team with I'm taking Phillip Rivers
to me he's one of the more underrated
quarterbacks we've seen in a long time
and it's no disrespect to the accolades
and the numbers that bein Roethlisberger
has put up I just like the toughness I
just like what Phillip Rivers does he
gets lost out there on the west coast I
get it
I remember the guy who played a game
with a torn ACL he put a brace on the
guy's got nine kids I think right now
about a guy that can play football
driving I would have every day from San
Diego to Los Angeles
with his team I just like the Moxie a
guy and to me no disrespect but every
time being Roethlisberger you know holds
the press conference being is going to
tell you the state of being in the state
of everybody else I just like the
demeanor of Phillip Rivers more but
being Roethlisberger is a Hall of Famer
but I'll take rivers on my yeah I just
need rivers to have more playoff wins
than children that's what I want him to
have at the end of his career and he's
got a little ways to go there booger and
here is why I said they have nine number
nine is on the way I just think this may
be his best opportunity and if we're
gonna talk about you know Philip Rivers
then you know we also have to give
anything in land a lot of credit for
what he's done with that football team
how many ought they want to go into
Kansas City get when my I didn't but
when you look at the manner in which
they did it no Melvin Gordon they were
down early everything about their game
says fold over it roll over and quit but
they didn't I just like where they're
headed man booger good to talk to you
hope you've enjoyed the season and have
fun with the Raiders and the Broncos
coming up on Monday night Danny was a
pleasure man anytime I've always
followed you for a long time man glad to
be on your show and thank you we'll take
you up on that booger McFarlane Happy
Holidays to you booger ESPN monday night
football analyst 8:15 eastern they'll
have the Raiders against the Broncos for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]